وفقًا لفريق عمل فيروس كورونا ، تم إجراء
أكثر من مليوني اختبار الآن
في الولايات المتحدة ، ومع ذلك
لا يزال هناك أشخاص يحتاجون إلى
الاختبار مثل العاملين في مجال الرعاية الصحية الذين
لا يمكنهم الحصول على اختبار ، فهذا جزء من سبب
وجود الكثير من الاهتمام الآن  في
نوع مختلف من الاختبارات ، قال طبيب اختبار الأجسام المضادة ،
فوي لشبكة CNN يوم الجمعة ، إنه
قريبًا ، أنا متأكد من أن
هذا سيحدث في غضون
أسبوع أو نحو ذلك ، سيكون لدينا
عدد كبير من الاختبارات المتاحة
ولكن  ما هي بالضبط الأجسام المضادة ، إنها
بروتينات في جهاز المناعة
تطورت بعد أيام من إصابة شخص ما
، والأجسام المضادة هي التي
تجعل الشخص محصنًا من
الإصابة مرة أخرى ، فهذا يعني شيئين
كنت مصابًا به سابقًا ومن
المحتمل الآن أن تكون محميًا على الأقل لبعض
الوقت  نعتقد أنها ستكون أداة
لمساعدتنا في إعادة الأشخاص إلى العمل ، فستكون
معلومات إضافية لأنه كما
تعلم إذا كان لديك جسم مضاد يعني
أنك تعرضت  يتضح من
ذلك أنه مع المعلومات حول
التشخيص يجب أن يساعد هذا هو السبب في أن
وكالات الصحة العامة في جميع أنحاء العالم تريد
اختبارات الأجسام المضادة هذه لأنها قد
تساعد بعض الأشخاص على العودة إلى حياتهم اليومية ،
فأنت تتذكر اختبار المسحة الذي نعرفه جميعًا
جيدًا تلك الاختبارات من أجل  الفيروس نفسه على
وجه التحديد مشاكل المواد الجينية
هي أولاً وقبل كل شيء في مرحلة ما
بعد أن تتعافى هذا الاختبار سيكون
سلبيًا وثانيًا ، واجه الكثير من
الأشخاص مشكلة في الحصول على هذا
الاختبار التشخيصي في المقام الأول ، يكون اختبار الأجسام المضادة
أكثر تحديدًا ، فهناك فقط
أسباب قليلة لوجود أجسام مضادة في
دمك ،
لقد حصلت على أجسام مضادة لشخص آخر عن طريق
حقنة من دمه ، حصلت على
لقاح يعلم جسمك صنع
الأجسام المضادة أو أنك أصيبت ،
يتطلب اختبار الأجسام المضادة عينة من
دمك وهذا الشريط الذي يحتوي على بروتينات
من الفيروس الموجود عليه ، إذا كان دمك
يتفاعل مع هذا الشريط ، فهذا يعني أن لديك
أجسامًا مضادة في دمك وأعتقد
أنه  قادرين على إخبارهم
براحة البال التي قد تأتي من معرفة
أنك مصاب بالفعل ، لديك
الجسم المضاد
الذي أنت في مأمن من الإصابة مرة أخرى بنسبة 99.9 في
المائة من الوقت
، ولذا أعتقد أن هذا سيكون
مطمئنًا جدًا لموظفي الرعاية الصحية في الخطوط الأمامية لدينا
فائدة أخرى لـ
مراقبة اختبار الأجسام المضادة في أماكن مثل
مقاطعة ميامي-دايد ، فلوريدا ، مقاطعة سانتا كلارا
بكاليفورنيا في تيلورايد كولورادو
، لقد بدأوا بالفعل في استخدام اختبارات الأجسام المضادة
للتعرف بشكل أفضل على
عدد الأشخاص الذين سيتفاجأ الكثير منهم
بمعرفة تعرضهم بالفعل
للفيروس أيا كان.  يتم
اختبار المتطوعين مرتين والغرض من ذلك
هو معرفة من يقوم بتحويل
وتطوير الأجسام المضادة ، مما يعني أن المتحدث باسم مركز السيطرة على الأمراض
قال لشبكة CNN أن الوكالة قد
استخدمت بالفعل هذه الأدوات لاقتباس
مراقبة اتصالات الأشخاص المصابين
وتحديد الأفراد الذين
قد لا تعرف العدوى الخفيفة أنهم
مصابون بإجراء اختبارات الأجسام المضادة
وتشغيلها مثل الاختبار للكشف  إلخ ،
كان الفيروس نفسه يمثل تحديًا
في عجلة من أمره للحصول على هذه الاختبارات للتسويق
، خفضت إدارة الغذاء والدواء الأمريكية المعايير التنظيمية
وما تبع ذلك كان الكثير من
الاختبارات غير الموثوقة وغير الدقيقة ، وهناك
سلسلة من اختبارات الأجسام المضادة
التي لم يتم التحقق من صحتها بعد بعض
الاختبارات  التي قد تكون متاحة على
الإنترنت قد تكون ذات حساسية
وخصوصية منخفضة للغاية وتمنحك تأكيدًا للقلق
بأنك إما تمنحك
إيجابية كاذبة أو سلبية خاطئة
مما يعني أنك قد تكون محميًا
قليلاً مما نحتاج إليه جميعًا من
أوروبا هنا  مريض إسباني يغادر
تنظيف وحدة العناية المركزة في النمسا ، وهو
الأول من نوعه في أوروبا الذي يفكر في
تخفيف الإغلاق ، قال المستشارة إنه
قد يُسمح للمتاجر الصغيرة يوم الاثنين بفتحها
بعد عيد الفصح ، لكن سيُطلب من العملاء
ارتداء أقنعة الوجه كما يفعلون
الآن في البقالة الأكبر  بتخزين بعض
الحكومات الأوروبية قائلة إن
منحنيات الإصابات المبلغ عنها تنخفض الآن
حيث لا تزال الولايات المتحدة والمملكة المتحدة ترتفعان ،
كل شيء سيكون على ما يرام  يخرج طفلًا في
إيطاليا ذات يوم كان مركز الزلزال حيث
تباطأت الوفيات الآن لأكثر من
أسبوع في فرنسا وإسبانيا التي كانت
بطيئة منذ الخميس في
هولندا أسبوعًا في البرتغال منذ يوم الجمعة
في إشارة إلى أن الوقت يمكن أن يظهر الخروج من
أسابيع  الحزن والخوف والعزلة ،
تقول الدنمارك أيضًا إنها قد تخفف قيودها ،
لا أن الخاتمة كانت على
خلفية خطيرة للغاية قال
رئيس الوزراء الدنماركي الأسبوع الماضي لدينا أسباب
للتفاؤل الحذر ، لكن إسبانيا التي
كانت حصيلة الضحايا شديدة
توخي الحذر والصبر بشأن  في معظم الأحيان ،
لم نتمكن من تخفيف
انتباهنا بشأن هذه الحالة في
رئيس وزرائهم ، علينا أن نواصل المضي
قدمًا بنفس الانضباط
وبنفس مسؤولية التضامن
وبنفس المثابرة ولكن كما لو كان هناك إشارة
للتحذير من تخفيف القيود  سريعة جدًا ،
ضربت اليابان نفسها بشكل أقل حدة في
الأشهر الماضية يوم الاثنين استعدادًا لحالة
الطوارئ وسط ارتفاع الحالات ،
وستكون المدة حوالي شهر واحد في ذروتها
نحن بحاجة إلى مزيد
من التعاون من المواطنين لتقليل الاتصال
بين الناس ، حيث يوضح الفيروس مدى
عشوائية وبدون هوادة ، فهو
تذكير بأنه حتى لو كان بإمكانك رؤية
الضوء ، فأنت لا تزال في النفق.
أوروبا
في الوقت الحالي خاصة هنا في إسبانيا ،
أعتقد أنه ليس هناك شك في ذلك ، فهذه
أوقات صعبة حقًا لأن
تخزين الناس يعد خيارًا لذلك لا يمكننا إيقاف
تكديس أو اكتناز أنا من فلوريدا وأنا
حاليًا في صحراء نيفادا
لا توجد طريقة للعودة إلى
فلوريدا الآن
[موسيقى
] سأؤمن الإغلاق ،
سيتم نقل الأشخاص من قبل الشرطة ، وبالتالي
يتم نقلهم باستمرار
وهو مرة أخرى إذا كنت سائق شاحنة ويمكنك
الذهاب  المنزل حيث لديك منزل اليوم
لا بأس به ، ولكن دعنا نقول أنك
تعيش في الأساس في شاحنتك ، ومن ثم فإن
نمط حياتك محظور بشكل أساسي ، والكثير منا في
مجتمع البدو يدركون تمامًا
ما يجري على علم به  منذ فترة
بدأت في عزل
[موسيقى] منذ حوالي
شهر ، لذا قبل تطبيق أي من اللوائح ،
كنت أعزل نفسي
بالفعل وكنت أفعل ذلك لفترة من
الوقت الآن لأنني أعتقد أنه
جزء مني أقوم بدوري من أجل  المجتمع ككل
علينا أن نعرف أننا في هذا
المجتمع معًا كمجتمع بدوي ،
أدرك الكثير منا أنه يتعين علينا أن
نتباطأ ونستقر لفترة قصيرة ، لذا
فنحن نصنع جميع أطعمتنا
وبمجرد عبورنا  على الحدود
وعلينا الحجر الصحي الذاتي ، لدينا الكثير من الطعام ،
لديك الكثير من الناس يقولون يا إلهي ،
لا أصدق مجوهراتك وهذه مهنتي ،
لا أعتقد أنني أريد أن
أعيش بأي طريقة أخرى ولدينا  كونك
بسبب الحرية وأنت تعيش بأقل من ذلك
وتدرك أنه يمكنك العيش مع عدد أقل من
الناس قد يظن أنه أمر مروع
مثل كيف يمكنك التعامل مع
العزلة في الجنوب عندما تكون في مثل هذا
المنزل الصغير لديكما مهمة في
الواقع  تسافر حول العالم في منزلك الصغير ،
ألا تفعل ذلك  هناك طريقة
خاصة جدًا هنا لإنشاء
مساحة لتناول الطعام لمدة 70 عامًا ، نعم عندما يتعلق
الأمر بالأشخاص الذين يعيشون
أنماط حياة بديلة ، لذا أعتقد أن أحد الاتجاهات التي لاحظتها بشكل عام في المنازل الصغيرة أو
ربما فان لايف هو أحد الاتجاهات
التي لاحظتها
بشكل عام  الأشخاص الذين يعيشون صغارًا لديهم
تكلفة معيشية أقل كثيرًا وكذلك في كثير من
الأحيان ليس لديهم مدفوعات الرهن العقاري
وليس لديهم قدر هائل من
الديون على رؤوسهم مما يعني
أن تكلفة المعيشة على
أساس يومي  هو أكثر بأسعار معقولة بحيث
يضيف بالتأكيد عنصرًا هائلاً من
المرونة عندما نمر
بصراع مثل هذا
أنت